It’s not easy being in charge; you have
to make all the big decisions, like what’s
best for everyone, how to improve things and
who gets the last bit of cake.
In the modern world, we the people generally
get some kind of say in who makes those decisions.
Well, most of the time at least.
In the past however, you were generally stuck
with royal lineage or whatever leader had
just murdered the previous boss and was now
using their head as a footstool.
Sometimes, leaders took this responsibility
well and tried to be just and fair.
But pretty often, they jumped head first into
the crazy pool and never bothered coming up
for air.
Today we look at some of the most psychopathic,
murderous and downright bananas rulers of
the ancient world.
If you’ve never heard of Ivan the Terrible,
his name is a pretty hefty clue that he wasn’t
exactly the most agreeable of guys.
Ivan IV was the Russian Tsar from 1547 to
1584, when he died from a stroke while playing
chess; it’s a dangerous game kids, you’ve
been warned.
Ivan was a leader of sorts from a very young
age, following his father as Grand Prince
of Muscovy in 1533, a historical area around
Moscow.
This was at the tender age of three when papa
died of a leg infection.
His mother went soon after, when he was eight,
but this was a suspected poisoning.
When Ivan was 16 he crowned himself Tsar of
all Russia, which at this point was a series
of territories run by different rulers.
Despite being a devout Christian, Ivan was
a little unstable, probably not helped by
all the leg and poison related deaths of his
parents and his first wife.
As a youngster he was said to have entertained
himself by tossing puppies off balconies.
And as he expanded his kingdom, taking on
the Turks, the Kazan, the Crimean Tatars and
many others, he enjoyed dealing out a good
punishment.
He would wall up entire cities so his troops
could bring a good 500 to 1000 prisoners out
every day and impale them or actually cook
them to death in giant frying pans.
Since he was a family man, he’d bring his
son along to watch, but eventually he killed
him too when he beat him round the head with
a pointed staff during a family feud.
Makes your Christmas dinners arguments seems
a little better now, doesn’t it?
Tamerlane the Great sounds a little friendlier
but he was one of the world’s biggest mass-murders.
Mao Zedong may have overseen up to 75 million
deaths but Tamerlane’s 15 to 20 million
is staggering considering there were only
some 350 million people on earth at that point.
He wiped out 5% of the entire global population.
And that’s without bombs or guns; you’ve
really got to applaud the hard-work and dedication
he must have put in.
Tamerlane, also known as Timur, founded the
Timurid Empire at the end of the 14th century
and claimed to be descended from Ghengis Khan,
who came about 200 years before and was also
pretty handy at the genocide game.
We’ve all got to have heroes, right?
Khan’s Mongol empire covered a much larger
area than Tamerlane’s and his armies are
thought to have slaughtered almost 60 million.
Tamerlane declared himself the “Sword of
Islam” and tried to rebuild the Mongol empire
under his religion.
But he wasn’t exactly at his most saintly
when he had 90,000 people in Baghdad beheaded
or when he forced people to die of slow suffocation.
He also had great towers built from his enemy’s
skulls, so he was pretty good at recycling
too.
Vlad the Impaler also has one of those delightfully
informative names.
Vlad was part of the House of Drăculești
and ruled Transylvania in the 15th century.
If this all sound a little familiar it’s
because he is the inspiration for Bram Stoker’s
novel, Dracula.
Vlad set about protecting his people and Christianity
from the surrounding Ottoman forces and did
a pretty good job of it.
He built a fearsome reputation, largely thanks
to his hobby of… you guessed it… impaling
people.
He once put all 20,000 men, women and children
of the city of Amlas on spiked sticks through
their bodies and faces.
But I don’t want you to think he was a one-trick
pony.
He also skinned, boiled, decapitated, blinded,
strangled, hanged, burned, roasted, hacked,
nailed, and buried alive, which sounds like
the menu at some kind of hipster pop-up restaurant;
I’ll have the strangled rabbit with buried
aubergine please, with a side of forced rhubarb.
And for desert, Vlad’s own head would fit
the bill as it’s said he was decapitated
by the Turks and it was sent to Constantinople
in a jar of honey.
The Roman Empire had a pretty good run of
crazy rulers so it’s hard to pick a worst
one but today we’re going for Caligula thanks
to quotes such as “I wish Rome had but one
neck, so that I could cut off all their heads
with one blow!”
He was the 3rd Emperor of Rome from AD 37
to AD 41 and got the nickname Caligula, meaning
Little Boots, from his time as a boy when
he accompanied his father, the general Germanicus,
to various battles.
He took over Rome from Tiberius and it’s
unclear whether he assassinated his predecessor
or not but it wouldn’t be that unlikely.
He then proceeded to spend just under 4 years
turning the palace into a giant brothel and
having anyone around him put to death if he
was angry or bored or just had a few minutes
to spare.
He was eventually assassinated by conspirators
who wanted to restore the Roman republic but
this failed and another emperor was installed
instead.
If you’re going to come up with a secret
plan to overturn the Roman government then
have a follow up plan at least, what would
the People’s Front of Judea think…
Aside from his notorious cruelty and obsession
with rather suspicious hanky panky, he also
appointed his favourite horse, Incitatus,
as an official priest, not the most stable
decision.
Not to be out done by all the men, we have
a female tyrant on the list as well.
Empress Wu ruled China from 690 to 705 and
is the only woman in Chinese history to have
power in her own right.
And she made sure she wouldn’t be forgotten
as she was a ruthless and psychotic leader
who drove her own people into misery.
She was renowned for ordering daily tortures
and forced suicides, as well as her sexual
depravity.
Wu started life in court as a concubine for
Emperor Taizong and somehow managed to escape
her expected retirement of going to the nunnery
after the Emperor died.
Instead, even though it was frowned upon,
she became a concubine for his son, Emperor
Gaozong.
She then worked her way up to Empress by some
pretty brutal means, including strangling
her own daughter to death in order to frame
the Emperor’s wife.
Some people will stop at nothing for a bigger
bedroom and an en-suite.
Soon Wu was installed as the new Empress and
was making most of the decisions.
When her husband died, her son was made emperor
but she soon had him exiled for not doing
what she wanted and eventually defied tradition
to take complete power herself.
The Byzantine Empire was a continuation of
the Roman Empire in the east, centered in
Istanbul, then called Constantinople.
From 976 to 1025, it was ruled by Basil II,
who also had one of those popular “The”-based
names; Basil the Bulgar Slayer.
And the Bulgars were Bulgarians, not that
weird type of wheat that your strange vegan
friends are obsessed with.
Basil really didn’t like Bulgarians, for
some peculiar reason, and he had numerous
wars with them, one of which lasted over 30
years.
He was finally victorious in the Battle of
Kleidon and had a rather over-the-top punishment
for his 15,000 prisoners.
His army used red hot pokers and daggers to
blind all 15,000 of them but left every hundredth
person with one eye so they could lead the
rest home because he didn’t want them all
milling about, causing queues for the showers
and stuff.
Apparently the Bulgarian ruler died of a stroke
when he saw what had been done to his people.
Basil, on the other hand, was thoroughly pleased
with himself and repeated the trick again
in Macedonia, two years later.
A good joke’s a good joke, I guess.
And finally, a popular favourite; Attila the
Hun, also known as Attila the Scourge of God.
Attila’s empire grew in the middle of the
5th century and stretched all the way from
Germany into Russia.
He set out to destroy the Roman Empire and
just generally anyone who disagreed with him.
His nickname “Scourge of God” was due
to the fact that he was so damn awful, everyone
thought he must be some sort of holy punishment,
much like how the modern world feels about
Piers Morgan.
He once met Saint Ursula, a holy virgin, and
asked to marry her.
She turned him down and in a fit of rage he
had her killed, along with 11,000 of her companions.
It’s even thought that he could have drunk
some of the women’s blood.
So although the current political climate
is pretty heated, I suppose it’s good to
know that things could be worse.
But then again, just like your CV, I’m sure
some things have been exaggerated over time
and who knows what stories will be written
in the future about Donald the Trump, Vladimir
the Shirtless and Boris the total Johnson.